[Music]
we're coming up on the one-year
anniversary of the world shutting down
because of a deadly pandemic
one year isn't that crazy
man time flies when you're alone hitting
new lows of depression
a lot has changed in the last year but
one thing that hasn't changed
are my feelings about the coronavirus
[Music]
we were young and foolish we were fun
and free
i had no idea the impact that you would
have on me
i never had to baby i never had you once
it's true yet the thought that i
someday might controls every single
thing that i do
i'm still scared of you baby
you still bring me to tears
we've only been taking that for 12
months but baby it feels like 20 years
with tears in my eyes there's no
surprise i get down on my knees to say
i was scared of you a year ago
and i'm still scared of you today
[Music]
the mere knowledge of your existence
baby
brought a tear to my eye i washed my
hands all day
and night look my skin's freaking
cracked and dry
i'm wondering if i'm ever gonna get you
are you
part of my feet i'm wondering if i'll
ever see my friends again i bet we
all
[Music]
baby you still make me stay home
you're the reason every last thing that
i do has to happen
over the phone with tears in my eyes
there's no surprise i get down
on my knees to say i was scared of you
a year ago and i'm still
scared of you today whoa
sometimes i cry in the bathroom yeah me
too buddy
i'm terrified it's insane i almost [ __ ]
my pants when i heard about the new
strain i'm so
afraid i'm so alone i would give my left
leg
to visit my mommy at home what's mommy
doing at home
guitar solo
[Music]
hey six feet six feet away you're too
close
[Music]
i'm still keeping my surfaces clean you
still got me willing to do things i'm
ashamed
of to get that sweet vaccine with tears
in my eyes there's no surprise i get
down on my knees to say
i was scared of you a year ago
and i'm still scared of you today
i live in constant fear all right
[Music]
you